There's a chapter in my book called
don't ever don't let your children do
anything that makes you dislike them and
I'm pretty happy about this chapter,
although I suspect it will be rather
controversial and it's predicated on the
observation that many people hurt their
children physically and psychologically,
you know,
because everyone gets sentimental about
the relationship between parents and
children.
But that's especially in relationship to
themselves because they think,
well,
you know,
of course I'm going to be a good parent.
It's like it's not so bloody obvious
that you're going to be a good parent.
You know,
and so,
and then what I see happening with
people who don't know how to discipline
their children is that the children run
roughshod over them in their,
let's call them a hierarchical disputes
because children push for position and
hierarchy and they do that behaviorally
to sort of feel out the contours of the
social structure.
So you know your kid locked perfectly
fine at home,
let's say at the dinner table,
but then you take them to a stranger's
dinner table and all of a sudden they
act out and you think what's up with
you,
your little monster and what's up is
that they're trying to figure out what
the power structure is in the new.
They don't know this of course,
but they're acting this out there trying
to figure out if the same rules apply in
this new situation as apply in the old
situation and they can't ask that and
they don't even know that they are rules
exactly there regularities that they've
learned and so they'll test and test and
then you have to show them that.
Yeah,
it's the same here.
It's the same in this situation,
but lots of parents are very uneasy with
disciplining their children.
Partly because there they believe that
if you give a child infinite freedom
that's best for them and that
constraints are inappropriate,
which is really just.
Well,
I don't know what to say about that
except it's so untrue that that it's
very difficult to think of anything
that's more untreated now,
but also the thing is,
is if you let your children take
advantage of you,
if you have an ounce of spine and an
ounce of aggression,
which you do,
especially if you don't admit it,
then you will take revenge on your
children.
You know,
so if they have a temper tantrum in a
grocery store and embarrass you,
which Gerald,
who's can,
he can do quite effectively,
you know,
because you wouldn't let them have that
pack of crayons or a chocolate bar and
then you know you,
you tell yourself it's okay and that you
still,
you know that that really didn't make
you that angry and it's okay,
but you're fuming inside and then you go
home and half an hour later maybe the
child is doing some interesting little
bit of work,
maybe artwork or something or does
something good and comes up for a
reward.
It's like the probability that you're
going to reward that child properly
under those circumstances,
zero.
You're going to take the opportunity to
take your revenge,
and if you don't know that,
then you're not much of the parent.
And so part of the trick with kids is
that if your child is doing something
that makes you dislike them,
that you have to figure out how to stop
them from doing that and teach them how
to do it properly.
And you have to talk to your wife to
make sure that you're not being too much
of a monster,
you know?
And the same with her.